for the Federal Reserve controlling
inflation is a little like playing a
game of darts just scored differently it
uses its tools to aim for that Bullseye
which in this case is two percent two
percent inflation Target two percent
Target and just like with darts the FED
doesn't always hit the center the
process of getting inflation back down
to two percent has a long way to go but
even getting close can help keep
inflation in check here's how two
percent became the fed's bullseye and
why that number can help guide the
health of the entire economy so where
did the FED come up with this Target in
the first place the answer New Zealand
suffering from persistent inflation in
the 1980s the country's Reserve Bank
initially set an inflation Target
between zero and two percent central
banks didn't use to tell people what
they were doing and in the 1990s they
began to experiment more with hey if we
tell people what it is we're actually
trying to do then maybe it'll make it
easier for us to achieve those goals
it's a strategy called anchoring when
nowhere inflation should run it here for
them to set prices and spend in a way
that's consistent with that goal and
that then helps the FED set policies to
maintain that level of inflation think
of it as the bullseye at the center of
the fed's monetary policy if you think
prices are going to be higher in a year
you'll demand higher wages now so there
can be a self-fulfilling element to
inflation expectations though targeting
has been in the fed's conversation for
decades the U.S only officially adopted
inflation targeting in 2012. when the
Fed was chaired by Ben Bernanke clearly
communicating to the public this two
percent goal for inflation over the
longer run should help Foster price
stability and moderate long-term
interest rates
and will enhance the committee's ability
to promote maximum employment in the
face of significant economic
disturbances
so what's so special about the number
two there isn't a lot of Empirical
research that says we've analyzed all
the different outcomes and two percent
is the right number for these reasons
that's really not how uh Central Bankers
came up with two percent the idea was
you wanted to have a level of inflation
that was low enough that people wouldn't
pay attention to how high prices were
going up for the fed the number two
achieves a few things for starters it's
not so low that the economy risks
deflation which is when prices fall and
can lead to lower wages and higher
unemployment the economy was at risk for
deflation during the Great Recession
between 2007 and 2009. falling prices
for a central bank can actually be a
worse State of Affairs than Rising
prices because if people think prices
are going to be lower tomorrow they
won't spend today and that can be very
hard to get out of lower inflation also
reduces the fed's ability to lower
interest rates because because rates
tend to move together with inflation if
you have a zero percent Target you'll
probably have lower interest rates and
the concern would be you'd have less
room to stimulate the economy when you
go into a recession but two percent is
also thought of as not too high AI High
inflation can weaken consumers spending
power the concern would be that
inflation might actually creep too high
and then you'd get into a world of
self-sustaining price increases where
higher prices feed on themselves and
that's the cycle the FED doesn't want to
find itself in the FED wants inflation
to hit as close to two percent as it can
over time to maintain a healthy economy
but sometimes it misses through the
2010s some economists were concerned
that inflation was consistently running
too low
a new policy in 2020 called flexible
average inflation targeting tries to
account for some of those periods rather
than always aiming for the bullseye the
FED tries to set policy to balance out
periods of lower inflation with periods
of slightly higher inflation with the
goal of averaging out at two percent
over time the worry was that the anchor
on inflation expectations was actually
drifting too low and so you could
recenter it by saying look we really
want to make sure people don't think two
percent is a hard ceiling it's a Target
if we're below it for a little while we
can be above it
somewhat for a little while but not
everyone agrees with the fed's two
percent Target strategy one concern is
that monetary policy is imprecise you
know monetary policy is a blunt
instrument this is more like going to
see a barber than having a surgery some
also argue that a higher rate of
inflation leaves more room for the FED
to adjust interest rates to avoid a
recession
whether or not inflation targeting is
actually effective is difficult to
measure inflation did settle for a time
after the policy was implemented in New
Zealand in the 90s in conjunction with a
number of other measures and it's still
relatively new in the U.S as we've
discovered there are shocks that can hit
the economy and you know it's it's
difficult to judge in real time I think
whether this is the right strategy
currently the FED reviews the framework
of its monetary policy every five years
the idea that the FED would make some
kind of change to its inflation Target
in the next couple of years seems like a
big stretch but they could debate at the
margins are there different nuances that
are formal strategy document hasn't
captured and those are the sorts of
things that you might expect to see in
the deliberations around any further
review of the framework but for now two
percent Remains the bullseye it will
keep aiming for foreign